la disney per il film cars 3 ha deciso
di contattarmi per mettere su un
qualcosa di veramente figo ovviamente
hanno chiamato l'unica persona senza
patente
vabbè va bene visto che il film fatto di
macchine a posto io non ho mai fatto un
video così figo
voi non avete idea di che cosa state per
vedere non ce l'avete non voglio tenermi
sulle spine oltre vi faccio vedere il
video e buona visione ragazzi
buona visione davvero
ragazzi appoggiati caschi e fate
attenzione perché la sfida di oggi non
sarà una passeggiata
il vostro avversario sarà davvero molto
duro
[Musica]
va bè ragazzi loro sono bravi ma questo
già lo sapevamo solo il fatto che loro
abbiano la patente e io no mi fa
lavorare però va bene vieni motoman se
la cavano
[Musica]
si sentono conti rai al problema è che
qui
niente a nessuno
[Musica]
i ragazzi non è andata come pensavo però
un altro tentativo questa volta andrà
meglio
[Musica]
vediamo se sfuggita questo
ragazzi ma la vostra età ancora state
giocare con le macchinine andiamo che vi
porta chino e stato bellissimo io voglio
di farlo adesso adesso voglio rifarmi è
stato figli voi non avete idea in questo
stanza bruciano a tutti gli schermi
stato fighissimo e c'è una tastiera
enorme piena di botto ma sarà stata una
roba chilometrica con duemila molto ma
di finissimo e io dovevo mettere le
trappole e stato e stato veramente una
figata con la figlia privata che mi sono
seduto sulla sedia ho visto la tastiera
piena di bottone schiacciare a caso
perché io sono come i bambini e poi
erano trappole video fatto esplodere
cose schizzare bolle sapone finissima e
soprattutto il fatto che io sia con
valentino rossi mi conferisce patente
automaticamente ho bisogno di fare
l'esame io ho fatto video con valentino
rossi
una volta gli ho anche chiesto la foto
ho sorriso per un'ora come un ebete
mentre lui cercava di avere un dialogo
con me ma quella è un'altra storia di
ragazzi io sono contentissimo di tutto
questo una prima di concludere andrei
anche a vedere che cosa ne pensano i
piloti perché quello che avete visto
sono i più noti dello ski racing team
che io avevo già conosciuto tipo ne
hanno un anno fa 2 2 anni fa mi sa non
mi ricordo più abbandonati texture figli
molti di loro li conosco e mi hanno
mandato un video dove vi salutano e vi
dicono cose tipo inveiscono contro di me
perchè gli ho rovinato la pista andiamo
a vedere questo video insieme a profani
j che ha disturbato con la schiuma e
fumogeni
lo ringrazio ringrazia che non vi ho
sabotato i telecomandi
ciao favi non ti conosco so chi sei per
fama per per fame e non per farlo di
persona non ti conosco dai però di
conoscerti presto
vengo in macchina se tivamente quando
vuoi se vuoi venire
sfido grazie i banchi o come si chiamano
ora di comandante favia prati tutti i
modi ad ostacolarsi a disturbarci ma ce
l'abbiamo fatta lo stesso e fa vj e
sistemi di con questa cosa quando l'ho
incontrato la prima volta questo ragazzo
mi ha raccontato che una volta dei miei
fan e lo hanno fermato chiedendogli un
autografo
perché l'avevano scambiato per me bar
dove ce l'avete visto stato miliardi
forse siamo due cose insieme e bello
bello molto bello di e mi aspettavo che
fa vigili se qua oggi anche perché noi
abbiamo sofferto un caldo pazzesco lui a
casa sua non far niente facile quindi
non fa niente zio innanzitutto avevi il
cappello quindi si è avvantaggiato però
a parte questo non ti credere che questa
roba chiamata comunemente luce per i
video non faccia calore non ti credo
veramente che sembra vivere il sole
puntato in faccia di continuo e orribile
chiamare ce lo spieghiamo con le moto
con le moto
io ci tengo a vivere ancora una
sessantina d'anni almeno cioè essendo
ottimista comunque ragazzi io ringrazio
i ragazzi non sky racing team sede
fantastici soprattutto to back perché se
mi somigli vuol dire che se un gran figo
come me al massimo riportiamo un po
insieme chi cede un po di ragazzo un po
e non tutte sono né ci allarghiamo è
ragazzi io spero che questo video vi sia
piaciuto io mi sono veramente divertito
tantissimo ringrazio alla disney di
cuore per avermi preso in questo
progetto è enorme perché c'era valentino
c'erano i ragazzi lo stile racing team e
poi ci sono io che sono stato bocciato
quattro volte all'esame della patente
nel caso lo stesse chiedendo no non
inventato sono stato bocciato con
trovate l'esame della patente con un
cast re non c'è scritto quando esce dal
14 settembre ho toccato la lampada mi ha
fatto malissimo non mi era ancora
successo sta roba fantastico caldo
pazzesco
dal 14 settembre al cinema un film
scottante
io spero che video vi sia piaciuto rai
come sede dei vigili ha lasciato un
commento che non mi piace soprattutto
verbale ma anche per me e becco anche
perfetto soprattutto perché praticamente
solo per ben il 60 si rischia che vi si
svegliavano servito da ragazzi
[Musica]